rozès place maintenant à une information
scientifique de grande importance des
chercheurs de nuire si genève ont
réalisé une première en génétique ils
ont réussi pour la première fois chez
les mammifères a créé en quelque sorte
des doubles en transplantant des noyaux
de souris d'un embryon à un ovule martin
à la réunio me dit comment ça s'est
passé est ce qu'on peut attendre de la
découverte
ce n'est pas la première fois qu'une
telle expérience est tenté mais c'est
effectivement la première fois au monde
qu'elle révise par micromanipulation
d'envrion est d'avis ces chercheurs sont
parvenus à fabriquer des sosies
génétique de souris ce qu'on appelle des
clous en dhr la technique est courant en
botanique ou par bouturage on obtient
bien des végétaux exceptionnelle sur les
animaux inférieur où l'on a pu obtenir
des copies de grenouille mais jamais
jusqu'à ce jour chez les mammifères où
l'on ne parvenait pas à construire à
partir de cellules isolées des sosies
génétique vieux rêve de l'humanité
tout n'est pas encore gagné mais une
étape est franchie voici comment ces
chercheurs s'y sont ils ont prélevé dans
une femelle
récemment c'est condé dea instinct très
précoce ou les noyaux de l'eau du lait
du spermatozoïde sont inclus proches
mais pas encore fusionné les ont prélevé
par pipette laissant la cellule avec son
cytoplasme libre de tout noyau
parallèlement ils ont prélevé dans une
autre cellule dans une autre souris
d'une autre couleur un embryon très
précoce au niveau la macif cellule r d
aux prises un noyau et ils ont décidé de
le transplanter ce noyau va être
introduit dans la cellule vidé de ses
propres noyau de souris blanche
ce nouvel of ainsi bricoler noyau de
souris noire avec cytoplasme de ces deux
souris blanche va se diviser pour donner
un embryon qui sera transplanté dans une
mère adoptive blanche et qui donnera
naissance à une copie de la souris noire
voici le bébé reste à savoir à quoi cela
peut servir
il est fondamental mais je mets en
tiendrait un point particulièrement
important qui a intéressé les
embryologistes depuis de très nombreuses
années à savoir les le problème des
potentialités des noyaux des cellules
différenciées de manière très simple une
cellule de rein contient l'information
pour une cellules rénales est ce qu'elle
contient l'information pour l'ensemble
des cellules manière de répondre à cette
question c'est de prendre le noyau de le
mettre dans un oeuf et de laisser le
tous développé et voir si ce noyau va
gouverner la naissance des cellules du
pancréas du foie du cerveau que sais-je
sur le plan pratique je ne pense pas que
ça apporte d'éléments essentiellement
nouveau par contre sur le plan
fondamental et dans la mesure où le
cancer est une maladie fondamental de la
cellule de la vie cellulaire tout ce qui
apporte une lumière sur les aspects
fondamentaux de la vie cellulaire peut
apporter des lumières sur le phénomène
quelques fondamentale quel cancer
autre question qui nous fait un peu
rêver
si les clones se multiplient si les
expériences se multiplient
à quand les einstein les mozart est pour
demain
alors oui on peut rêver il ya d'autres
gens qui vous dirait que c'est un
cauchemar que sais-je mai
là je crois qu'il faut répondre à deux
niveaux d'une part il faut bien préciser
qu on n'en est pas là dedans même dans
le chez la souris puisqu'il s'agit de
noyaux provenant d'embryons et non pas
de souris adultes
là vous me parlez de mozart qui est un
homme adulte et que d'autre part il faut
transférer les expériences à l'homme
enfin à supposer qu'on ait réussi à
garder les cellules de mozart et leur
noyau que ces noyaux été réimplantés
dans un ovule humain et qu'on ait obtenu
une centaine de mozart naissant petit
bébé mozart
rien ne dit qu'ils seraient devenus des
mozart